pour la première fois chez nous le
déplacement de la commission filière
ronde de l'inao l'institut national des
appellations d'origine commission crier
il y à peine un peu plus d'un an et on
pourrait même parler de surprise et
prend par les marseillais dans son
caddie bonjour monsieur s'assied un jour
vous êtes président de l' eau sérum
agricole de martinique
c'est une première donc or notre robe
est appellation d'origine contrôlée
depuis 1996
c'est à dire depuis 22 ans et cette
filière cette commission vient à peine
d'être créée oui mais on connaît on
avait aussi en 96 obtenu la hausse est
donc c'était aussi la première aoc sur
deux un alcool blanc
les premières a aussi aussi sur du rhum
est la seule à l'heure actuelle alors en
96 on avait obtenu cela après avoir
aussi eu l'obligation de par le code
rural que l'inao soit compétent et
d'hommes puisque avant il n'était pas
compétent et alors après donc on a eu un
seul représentant au sein de l'inao
puisqu'on peut y aussi des cotisations
et en échange on avait eu un simple
représentant quitter man a mené son qui
est à une personne qualifiée et donc le
mont vert dans les sons voilà claudine
madame claude darmon et son et comme on
a
aussi a été rejoint par les ige c'est à
dire qu'en 2009 l'europe a obligé tous
les toutes les dénominations
géographiques a passé 70 g sous aoc
indications géographiques
donc toutes les tous les autres
départements ont voulu passer enneigé
mais pas en aoc donc la martinique reste
la seule aoc et à partir de là donc on a
demandé à voir aussi une filière rome au
sein de l'inao puisque l'hymne aoc des
producteurs de vin ces des producteurs
de fromage c'est toute production qui
est labellisée haute en bio que la belle
rouge mais aussi des mesures
géographique et nous on a fait partie de
la commission boissons spiritueuses et
au sein et à l'armagnac calvados le
cognac et on paie une des plus grosse
part de cotisation donc on a demandé à
avoir des représentants et on nous a
proposé en attendant de changer le code
rural de d'avoir une filière rome et
donc vous avez dans cette commission
trois représentants du yen à eau mais
aussi un représentant pour chaque iger
et aoc présente alors il faut quand même
signaler et monsieur soucier que
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée
c'est depuis de 1996 les démarches
avaient débuté depuis le début des
années 70 ça pour notre rome oui parce
qu'on a obtenu un label rouge en 1973 ça
c'était aussi importante si on avait
déjà pris l'option que il tâte yves à ce
moment là et donc on avait demandé
notamment tous les anciens distillateur
avait demandé à l'époque à passer en aoc
et le problème c'est que là aussi on est
ailier now n'était pas compétent d'une
part dans les dom et qu'une a aussi ça
ne se construit pas comme ça il faut à
la fois une notoriété mais il faut aussi
que votre produit puisse par dégustation
se distinguer de tout autre donc il a
fallu mettre en place tous les systèmes
et à tel point qu'on en est aussi une
aoc modèle savent où le savoir parce que
dans les spiritueux
on est là cela aussi qui contrôle à la
dégustation tous les roms avant la mise
en consommation
oui ça c'est vraiment notre cheval de
bataille est ce qui fait la force au
sida martinique alors cette filière rome
cette commission filière roma qui a vu
le jour
en février 2018 cette visite aujourd'hui
de cette commission de filières rome de
l'inao
c'est pour faire quoi exactement c'est
juste pour vérifier que les choses se
passent bien parce qu'on va vers une
évolution des choses c'est pourquoi
exactement cette visite alors on a
demandé à ce qu'il soit installé on
aurait pu l'installer à paris tout
bêtement on a demandé ce soit installée
dans les dom et notamment donc la
martinique et la guadeloupe puisque
c'est là où aussi on a une des grosses
productions de lance de la guadeloupe
parce que c'est une riche idée mais
c'est une niche dans le pays producteurs
de renom pour ça que la réunion finale
se fait
ce fait aujourd'hui de toute la
commission et pourquoi faire venir donc
la commission ici c'est pour montrer
surtout aux experts l'inao qui ne sont
pas producteurs de rhums puisqu'on a le
président c'est un producteur de vin
date s on a aussi un producteur de
cognac la maison ici donc c'est pas
n'importe qui non plus et donc c'est
même le président de comité national
libre et sans spiritueuses donc
l'avantagé de leur montrer aussi notre
production nos spécificités et à partir
de là ce sont eux qui vont nous défendre
comité national donc c'est aussi parce
que peut-être parfois au comité national
on raisonne plutôt dans les produits
qu'on connaît et nous on a nos
spécificités donc créé une filière rome
c'est aussi avoir des spécificités de
connaître le rhum agricole c'est
important hélas ce qui se dit ce qu'il
en ressort c'est qu'ils sont très très
agrément surpris les ses productions et
qu'ils la comprennent beaucoup mieux et
que et après c'est aussi pour nous
d'avoir des interlocuteurs et d'avoir
une représentativité aliéna au même si à
terme on demande à ce qu'il en est des
vrais représentants comité national
alors est ce que cette aoc pour le rhum
martiniquais est menacée à l'intérieur à
l'extérieur
aujourd'hui au moment où on parle alors
on à la menace est aussi une réussite
reconnaissance de réussite et ça on l'a
eu assez rapidement parce que donc au
départ agricole était un terme on
certain rigoler puisque c'est un terme
français on nous parlait de paysans de
trucs comme ça et maintenant eh bien
c'est un terme ou on essaye de nous ne
prendre il ya même une katché sa du
brésil qui vient de se faire appeler
rhum agricole brésil et pourtant c'est
un non protégé au niveau européen on
essaie l'europe va essayer de protéger
le niveau de l'eau mais ça c'est encore
autre chose c'est pas gagné et donc on a
pour le martinique aussi dès le début
des copies on a vu apparaître dans les
spiritueux le nom martinique en inde en
chine et l' avantage d'être aussi une
appellation dénomination française c'est
que c'est l'état français et donc l'iiao
nos cotisations servent aussi à ça c'est
que l'état français va nous défendre
jusque là bas donc on a eu les attaques
de l'extérieur avec l'étiquette
martinique l'étiquette a aussi on a vu
dit récemment avec cette marque
vénézuélienne
diplomatico si j'ai bonne mémoire qui
abat qui distribuaient des bouteilles de
rhum avec la leur c'est pas distribuer
encore sur les bouteilles mais c'est sur
leur publicité sur internet maintenant
il parle d' aoc alors que normalement
pour eux c'est plutôt d autres termes
qui sont affiliés donc c'est aussi je
pense une envie de copier et cette envie
de copier ben c'est parce que c'est une
réussite
et c'est là où il faut qu'on se protège
et s'assied à l'extérieur donc l'état
français à une veille sur tous ses
produits mais c'est aussi en interne
puisque on a aussi des gens qui par
exemple usurpent le nom martinique
c'était bien quand vous êtes à aussi il
vous êtes les seuls à pouvoir utiliser
martinique où tout terme ou allusions ou
carte ou documents qui permettraient de
de faire une allusion à martinique et ça
c'est hyper important
je sais ça protège notre production donc
on voit des attaques avec les brésiliens
les indiens les péruviens les
vénézuéliens qui essaie de reprendre la
belle martinique label aoc
il y a également des attaques à
l'intérieur je me souviens il ya
quelques années vous avez fait allusion
à claudine vernon et son qui disait que
par exemple sur son territoire du carbet
pour la ruine et son pour ne pas la
citer aimé que l'implantation d'une
société hlm à côté de la distillerie à
côté de plantation pouvait nuire à cette
appellation d'origine contrôlée
là aussi un l'inao peut intervenir oui
parce que là c'est aussi une des
différences avec les ige les fameuses
indications géographiques comme peuvent
avoir la guadeloupe et autres puisque
vous êtes frileux de savoir audi fait la
différence c'est que par exemple on peut
produire de la can pour faire du home
guadeloupe sur tout le territoire la
guadeloupe alors que nous on a des
territoires vraiment on fait de
l'élitisme on prend les meilleurs
terroirs pour avoir les meilleurs cannes
et au final avant le meilleur rhum et
dans ces cas là donc on a des surfaces à
hausser un peu comme dans le bordeaux
comme dans la
le bleu bourgogne et autres et ces
surfaces sont protégés aussi par le code
rural
c'est à dire que chaque fois qu'il ya un
pb lui chaque fois qu'une modification
de son affectation possible que j'aie lu
d'urbanisme voilà qui pourrait porter
atteinte à cette surface ils sont
obligés de consulter le ministère de
l'éducation distillerie peut faire peu
gêné la progression de projet immobilier
par exemple parce que c'est plutôt à ce
projet immobilier faut le voir dans
l'autre sens à mon avis c'est plutôt
parfois le projet immobilier qui peut
gêner la survie simplement de la vie
celle là on parle pas c'est là dit cyril
va pas chercher comme ça des terrains
autour el pais les a parfois un planteur
aussi c'est pas forcément des services a
peut être un planteur les planteurs
parfois c'est son seul terrain son sol
gagnent pas donc à gilles alain gerber
il ya eu dans cette fois c'est aussi eu
des cas d'un peu dans le sud par tout
n'at il donc à ce moment là ils sont on
est obligé de consulter le ministère de
l'agriculture et donc liana ou ailier
now nous consultent puisque nous on a
aussi un avis à donner et à ce moment là
on dit si on veut vraiment protégé alors
c'est un bon moment ça a marché sur deux
trois petites choses pour donner un
exemple plus plus concret plus marquants
en france par exemple on a déplacé une
ligne de train pour un grand vignoble et
qu'elle un avantage de la hausse et
c'est c'est une garantie pour les
distilleries c'est une garantie pour les
planteurs c'est une garantie pour le
consommateur ça crée des emplois par
exemple ah oui alors là aussi comment
dire s'est il faut le regarder aussi du
côté du consommateur c'est à dire dire
on a le meilleur homme du monde tout le
monde peut le dire par contre garantir
par l'état français que vous avez une
production spécifiques qui vous donne un
goût spécifique et que ces faits dans la
région de production selon les méthodes
traditionnelles
ça c'est là où c est cette aoc là elle
est là bon en france tout le monde
connaît un fromage le roquefort tout le
monde va connaître compter tout ça mais
personne ne connaît vraiment aoc gier
mes parents à l'étranger quand vous
allez en chine notamment au japon
là vous êtes vraiment c'est porteur
c'est à dire que c'est la france qui
vous garantit un produit et là vous avez
les sentiers vous vendez beaucoup mieux
c'est à dire que la bouteille
de rome martiniquaise va arriver avec le
producteur martinique producteurs
français y aura même le drapeau bleu
blanc rouge qui sait peut-être pourquoi
pas le drapeau bart il faudra peut-être
faire un référendum pour savoir lequel
mais ça ça peut vraiment permettre la
création d'emplois on en a déjà fait
parce que bon alors au niveau planteurs
par exemple on avait un solde négatif
avant la hausse et maintenant on a un
solde positif c'est à dire qu'on a de
plus en plus de planteurs qui veulent
s'installer
on essaye de garantir aussi le paiement
des planteurs puisque le vent le rhum se
vend de plus en plus cher et on a aussi
un développement à l'international donc
là aussi une prix mobilisation des roms
vieux et autres et on a aussi les sites
puisque le spiri tourisme n'est pas
innocent non plus puisque c'est aussi
développer cette image s'est pas non
seulement la bouteille qui la véhiculent
mais c'est aussi toute l'histoire qu'il
faut s'approprier quand vous avez des
visiteurs c'est aussi vendre toutes ses
productions
merci beaucoup monsieur s'assied marque
s'assied président de l' eau sérum
alcoolo martinique on aurait pu parler
pendant des heures encore de 7 de cette
aoc de la filière rome merci d'avoir été
ce matin avec nous dans ce millésime en
journée
[Musique]